if you can maybe from a fantasy chess
perspective uh analyze
uh ding vs nepo who wins
the current the two people that would
play
if you're not playing generally i would
consider that ding has a slightly
better overall chest strength um what
are the strengths and weaknesses of each
if you can kind of summarize it um
so
nepo he's
even better at calculating short lines
than i am um
but he can sometimes like a little bit
of
a little bit of depth uh like his in
short lines is an absolute calculation
monster he's extremely uh he's extremely
quick but he can sometimes like a bit of
depth also recently um he's improved his
openings quite a bit so now he
um he has a lot of a lot of good ideas
and he's very very
solid um ding is not quite as well
prepared but he has
an excellent understanding of
dynamics and imbalances in in chess i
would uh i would say what do you mean by
imbalances um imbalances like bishop
bishops against knights and material
imbalances you can take advantage of
those
yes i would say he's very very good at
that and understanding the you know the
dynamic factors as we call them like
material versus time
uh especially
i think nepal got the better of him and
the candidates so what's your sense why
ding has an edge in the in the
championship i feel like
individual past results hasn't
necessarily been
a great indicator of world championship
results uh i feel like over overall
stress strength is more
more important i mean to be fair i only
think like ding has a very small edge
like difference is not big at all but
our individual head-to-head record was
probably the main reason that a lot of
people thought nepo had a good chance
against me as well it was like
four to one in his favor
before
the match but that was just another
example of why that may not necessarily
mean anything also in our case it was a
very
very low sample size i i think
about the size of of them of of the
match in total 14 games and that
generally doesn't
doesn't mean much how close were those
games would you say in your mind for the
previous championship
so that game 6 was a turning point where
you won
um was there any doubt in your mind that
you know like if you do a much larger
sample size that you'll get the better
of nippo no no larger sample size is
always good for me
so world championship it's a great
parallel to
to football
because it's a low scoring game
and
if the better
player or the better team scores
they win
most of the time oh that's generally for
for big for championships or in general
yeah for for championships like they
generally
generally win uh because the other
slightly weaker team they're good enough
to
defend to make it very very difficult
for the others but when they actually
have to create the chances then they
have no chance and then it very often
ends with a blowout as it did in our our
match if i hadn't won game six it
probably would have been very very close
he might have edged it
there's obviously a bigger chance that i
i would have edged it but this is just
what happens a lot in in chess but also
in in in football that matches our
clothes and then
they
somebody scores somebody scores and
things things change and this gives
people the illusion that the matchup was
very close yeah which
while actually it just means that
the nature of the game makes
the matches close very often but it's
always
much more likely that one of the teams
is gonna or one of the players is gonna
break away than the others and in other
matches as well even though
a lot of people before the match in 2016
uh against uh
um against karyakin there were people
who thought
before the match that i was massively
overrated as
as a favorite and
that
essentially
the match was pretty pretty close like
whatever
60 40 or some people even stayed like 55
45 and what i felt was that match
went very very wrong for me and
i still won
and some people saw that as an
indication that the pre-match
probabilities were probably a bit closer
than people thought well
i would look at it in that in the way
that everything went wrong and i i still
i still won which probably means i was a
pretty big favorite to begin with
you